la medicina moderna ha cambiato
radicalmente la storia dell'umanità voi
pensate che quando l'italia è stata
unificata nel 1861
l'aspettativa di vita alla nascita era
di 34 anni questa era la durata media
della vita oggi siamo più di 80 anni e
la medicina ha contribuito radicalmente
ma non è stato sempre così e la medicina
moderna che ha avuto l'impatto più
importante il ventesimo secolo è stato
il secolo del cambiamento quello appunto
in cui sostanzialmente le persone sono
state aiutate ad avere una vita lunga e
le malattie hanno cominciato ad essere
curate questo perché perché l'ingegneria
la biologia la chimica le cosiddette
scienze dure sono entrate ad aiutare i
medici che prima non avevano altro che
il loro buon senso la loro umanità la
loro empatia nei confronti dei pazienti
ma non avevano tecnologie non avevano
strumenti pensate alle grandi scoperte
del ventesimo secolo
la risonanza magnetica la tomografia
assiale computerizzata per analizzare
fare delle diagnosi approfondite farmaci
straordinari come gli ace inibitori
inibitori della pompa protonica gli
antidepressivi che hanno cambiato
radicalmente la storia delle malattie e
poi alcuni interventi chirurgici
importantissimi l'infarto acuto del
miocardio
l'attacco di cuore fino praticamente
agli anni sessanta era quasi sempre
mortale oggi è una malattia che viene
curata perché c'è l'angioplastica perché
ci sono tutta una serie di strumenti
importanti e naturalmente la chirurgia
ha fatto passi avanti enormi un tempo
bisognava aprire il corpo con quella
chirurgia tradizionale che lasciava
nelle cicatrici indelebili oggi c'è una
chirurgia mininvasiva laparoscopica
basta un piccolo buchetto e all'interno
si può entrare del corpo per fare degli
interventi chirurgici straordinariamente
importanti pensate alla cataratta un
tempo non c'erano gli occhiali non
c'erano la possibilità di correggere
appunto la cataratta che lo scorrimento
del cristallino
oggi abbiamo degli interventi che fanno
sono fatti ambulatorialmente cioè
sostanzialmente una persona con la
cataratta viene gli viene sostituito il
cristallino viene messa una lente e
restituita la vista in maniera
straordinaria ora che cosa significa
questo significa che la vita dell'uomo è
radicalmente cambiata ma ancora di più
cambierà e sta cambiando in questo xxi
secolo quello che sta cambiando la
storia della medicina sono
sostanzialmente due cose la decodifica
del genoma umano voi sapete che c'è
stato un programma straordinario a cui
ha partecipato anche l'italia in cui si
è letta la chiave del genoma umano se
sostanzialmente si è capito come sono i
meccanismi che dal dna portano al rna e
alla sintesi delle proteine e quindi si
è cominciato a capire che le malattie
insorgono li insorgono a livello
genomico e l'altra grande trasformazione
e la trasformazione digitale cioè i dati
e le tecnologie che ci aiutano a gestire
meglio le malattie soprattutto ci
aiutano a farlo in maniera efficace
efficiente e in tutto il mondo perché di
fatto quello che può essere oggi
realizzato e che magari all'altra parte
del mondo distante centinaia di
chilometri c'è un paziente e dall'altra
parte del mondo c'è un medico che lo può
assistere grazie alla telemedicina
grazie alla tecnologia digitale però
questo mondo moderno e il reso
complicato e la pandemia la manifestata
in tutta la sua gravità dagli squilibri
che comunque per questa crescita noi
abbiamo apportato al pianeta uno
squilibrio per cui oggi il mondo è caldo
si è riscaldato enormemente soprattutto
per l'inquinamento da combustibili
fossili e affollato mai come ora ci sono
tante persone che abitano il nostro
pianeta più di 7 miliardi diventeranno
10 miliardi nei prossimi 10 anni queste
persone vanno sfamate naturalmente
questo comporta dei costi e il mondo è
globalizzato
praticamente non ha confini anche
proprio grazie alle tecnologie la
facoltà di medicina e chirurgia agostino
gemelli dell'università cattolica ha
contribuito nei suoi 60 anni di vita in
maniera decisiva a questa evoluzione sia
con la ricerca perché ci sono state
delle ricerche importantissime che hanno
cambiato radicalmente la storia di
alcune malattie penso per esempio al
professor carlo patrono il nostro
farmacologo che ha inventato e ha
scoperto il ruolo protettivo
dell'aspirina nelle malattie
cardiovascolari e adesso sta studiando
il ruolo protettivo dell'aspirina nei
confronti delle malattie tumorali penso
al professor rocco bellantone che ha
inventato la tiroidectomia laparoscopica
cioè l'asportazione nella tiroide
semplicemente attraverso un piccolo
buchetto invisibile che porta via
l'organo malato senza compromettere
l'estetica e la funzionalità della
persona penso al professor scambia che
ha elaborato strategia straordinaria per
la chirurgia dei tumori ginecologici ma
sono tanti altri che popolano animano e
fanno sì che il policlinico gemelli sia
stato giudicato come il miglior ospedale
d'italia il primo ospedale oncologico
grazie al contributo dei medici ma anche
grazie al contributo dei ricercatori e
del personale che contribuisce
all'avanzamento delle conoscenze la
facoltà di medicina e chirurgia della
sede di roma è una delle avanguardie di
questa trasformazione tecnologica e
anche con la trasformazione genomica e
con la trasformazione digitale giocherà
un ruolo importantissimo però la
medicina contemporanea proprio per
quello che vi sto dicendo si
caratterizza anche per una crescente
complessità non c'è più soltanto il
medico e il paziente ma innanzitutto i
medici sono di diverse tipologie di
diverse specialità pensate a un
intervento di cardiochirurgia
un tempo c'era soltanto il medico che
faceva appunto un intervento sul cuore
di una persona oggi insieme a medico
ovviamente c'è l'anestesista oltre il
cardiochirurgo c'è il cardiologo oltre
il cardiologo c'è il riabilitatore
naturalmente ci sono i tecnici per la
circolazione extracorporea ci sono gli
infermieri c'è tutto il personale
c'è una macchina organizzativa
complessissima estremamente
all'avanguardia per quanto riguarda le
tecnologie ma anche proprio per questo
complessa e soprattutto costosa per cui
oggi la medicina non è soltanto e deve
naturalmente partire dal rapporto medico
paziente ma e organizzazione complessa
ci sono le tecnologie
ci sono molte risorse da allocare ci
sono la luce la logistica quindi ci sono
gli spazi da gestire questa è la grande
sfida molto spesso le organizzazioni
sanitarie non funzionano tanto bene si
parla spesso della cosiddetta malasanità
perché di fatto non vengono gestite
adeguatamente e soltanto attraverso una
gestione complessa e adeguata delle
strutture sanitarie che si riesce a
unire l'umanità che deve avere sempre un
atto medico perché alla fine c'è sempre
la persona al centro con la complessità
che in qualche modo deve essere
caratterizzata dalla medicina moderna
pensate alla cura dei tumori voi sapete
che in questo momento c'è una terapia
innovativa che si chiama immuno
oncologia e immunoterapia che
sostanzialmente sono farmaci biologici
che aiutano il corpo umano a reagire nei
confronti dei tumori ma tutto questo
deve essere preceduto da un attento
studio del paziente da una
personalizzazione delle caratteristiche
della patologia
da un'attenta analisi di quelle che
possono essere i terminali molecolari
che naturalmente in certi casi ricordate
le chemioterapia di un tempo provocavano
più danni effetti positivi mentre invece
noi oggi abbiamo la possibilità di
mirare le terapie personalizzandole e
individualizzato per questo però c'è
bisogno di una gestione adeguata di una
gestione complessa e molto spesso questa
non c'è
pensate al nostro servizio sanitario
nazionale nato nel
1978 è la più grande opera pubblica che
sia mai stata fatta significa che ogni
cittadino del nostro paese ma anche
quelli che persino risiedono
illegalmente chiamiamoli così grazie
alla legge turco napolitano hanno
diritto all'assistenza sanitaria nel
nostro paese senza se e senza ma
un'assistenza sanitaria che è pagata dai
contribuenti attraverso le tasse e che
viene erogata gratuitamente al momento
dell'uso però per far sì che questo
avvenga sistematicamente bisogna
gestirla bene bisogna evitare gli
sprechi
bisogna evitare procedure che siano
inutili o addirittura dannose tutto
questo comporta la necessità di
un'alleanza tra la politica che si
naturalmente garante democratico essendo
stata eletta dai cittadini
dell'allocazione delle risorse che
vengono raccolte con le tasse dai
manager cioè dai direttori ospedalieri
che devono far sì che la sanità funzioni
bene dai medici dai critici dal
personale sanitario che devono lavorare
al meglio delle loro forze e dei
cittadini dai pazienti che usufruiscono
di questi servizi siamo in italia
piuttosto indietro su questo fronte
abbiamo ottimi medici ma molto spesso
questi medici non vengono gestiti al
meglio anche in questo caso la
fondazione policlinico gemelli di roma è
caratterizzata da una gestione molto
attenta a cercare di conciliare questi
diversi valori ma l'altra grande
frontiera e la stiamo vedendo proprio
oggi con la pandemia è la frontiera
della informazione e della comunicazione
delle informazioni
circolano in maniera incontrollata in
media sociali social media internet è
stato uno straordinario avanzamento dal
punto di vista della disponibilità dei
dati
pensate che per la prima volta dati
sofisticati dal punto di vista
scientifico sono disponibili nello
stesso tempo ai medici e ai pazienti
prima li leggevamo soltanto sui libri di
medicina soltanto agli studenti di
medicina il professore di medicina
avevano accesso a queste informazioni e
quindi c'era un gap culturale
informativo nei confronti dei cittadini
enorme oggi invece queste informazioni
sono disponibili
qual è il problema particolarmente in
italia che molto spesso le persone non
sono in grado di interpretarle non hanno
ovviamente la cultura gli strumenti
tecnici e molto spesso queste
informazioni soprattutto quelle false
quelle sbagliate vengono diffuse in
maniera magistrale da dei comunicatori
da dei manipolatori che molto spesso
esasperano gli animi proprio perché si
parla della salute cioè della cosa a cui
le persone hanno più a cuore pensate a
quello che è successo in questa pandemia
si è sentito di tutto si è sentito che
questo era un virus che era stato creato
i cinesi dicevano dagli americani gli
americani dicevano dai cinesi creato in
laboratorio per danneggiare gli altri
per fare una sorta di guerra
microbiologica e per cercare di mettere
in difficoltà l'avversario si è detto
che questo virus è sostanzialmente una
creazione un falso di alcune persone
interessate a fare soldi
a buttare nel panico la popolazione
pensate ai vaccini vaccini sono gli
strumenti più sicuri più adeguati a
proteggere la salute perché di fatto
vengono dati a persone sane per evitare
di contrarre una malattia ma proprio per
questo sono molto spesso vittime del
loro successo fin dal loro inizio quando
genere elaborò il primo vaccino contro
il vaiolo le persone si spaventavano
perché pensavano appunto di ammalarsi di
vaiolo oppure di ammalarsi di malattie
sconosciute e le prime vignette anti
vaccini ste sono praticamente del giorno
dopo a quando jenner scoprì che
inoculando la sostanza che era presente
sulle mani dei vincitori delle vacche
poteva proteggere dal vaccino perché
quello che stava facendo era una
vaccinazione appunto cioè inoculazione
del virus vaccino delle vacche che di
fatto per noi uomini era assolutamente
nuovo proteggendoci dalla malattia ma
non facendoci avere il vaiolo e quindi
la vaccinazione è stata fin dal primo
momento diciamo ostacolata pensate alle
battaglie che anche persone importanti
per sante al mahatma gandhi che è stato
un fiero oppositore nella vaccinazione
anti poliomielitica quella che ha
salvato milioni di persone della morte e
migliaia di persone della paralisi
pentendosene in punto di morte perché ha
detto ho sbagliato perché bisogna
fidarsi della scienza bisogna fidarsi di
chi produce dei risultati così
importanti e pensate che il vaccino anti
poliomelitico quello di seven e dessert
non era stato brevettato da sal che
aveva detto mai possibile brevettare il
sole perché il vaccino nel momento in
cui viene creato deve essere nato ma
pensate alle resistenze che ci sono oggi
avete visto le persone in strada
addirittura in certi casi violente nei
confronti della opportunità di
vaccinarsi che contrasta con persone che
fanno file di chilometri e chilometri
per vaccinarsi in paese in cui purtroppo
non c'è il vaccino ma pensate a tutte le
false notizie che circolano a proposito
di inquinamento ambientale
radiazioni farmaci interessi e privati
come per esempio la diceria che con il
vaccino si inocula un microchip
deve essere collegato oppure che questo
vaccino una grande scoperta è destinato
a cambiare il nostro genoma e a
trasformarci geneticamente ora questo
tipo di sforzo deve essere fatto per
convincere le persone che questo non è
vero non solo non è vero ma li danneggia
in questo momento vedremo tante persone
purtroppo non vaccinate ammalarsi con
questa variante e delta che una variante
estremamente contagiosa nonostante
abbiamo a disposizione un bacino
importante per questo che in medicina
non soltanto dobbiamo fare buona scienza
e buona medicina dobbiamo anche saper
comunicare ed è quello che stiamo
facendo sono moltissime le attività
della sede di roma dell'università
cattolica finalizzate a questo scopo
sono moltissime le attività che cercano
di far capire alle persone come per
esempio importantissimo fare prevenzione
perché abbiamo gli strumenti per evitare
alle persone di ammalarsi come è
importantissimo fare la mammografia come
importantissimo fare il pap test come
importantissimo fare lo screening per il
cancro del colon retto sono moltissime
le iniziative che cercano di far capire
meglio quali sono i comportamenti
migliori per evitare la malattia
mangiare bene e poco fare una concreta e
costante attività fisica non bere troppo
alcool non fumare essere attento
all'inquinamento ambientale in
particolar modo alle radiazioni solari
tutto questo è fa parte di un continuo
sforzo che noi da roma per il mondo per
tutta l'italia facciamo nel cercare di
coniugare scienza e salute di coniugare
scienza e sviluppo economico in questo
momento nel mentre vi parlo l'italia è
uno dei paesi leader per quanto riguarda
questo sforzo pensate a quello che
succede contemporaneamente negli stati
uniti nella influenza spagnola nella
pandemia del 1919 su 75 milioni di morti
gli stati uniti ne ebbero
675.000 oggi la più grande superpotenza
scientifica e tecnologica del pianeta
gli stati uniti su 5 milioni di morti ne
hanno più di 700.000 è una parabola
incredibile e la dissoluzione
la differenza è nella incapacità di quel
sistema di avere una sanità pubblica
come ce l'abbiamo noi e soprattutto di
poter comunicare
come sto facendo io oggi a tutti quanti
l'importanza della scienza l'importanza
della salute l'importanza di andare
avanti e verso un futuro migliore